if you're running a business with
operation setup this this that and your
margins are only 20
a business has got to make their 20 so
meaning whatever dana and those guys
have done has worked and it's made a lot
of people rich can they improve in
certain ways if they could what would
you say would be a way they could
improve it jake made his proposal saying
take the twelve thousand fifty thousand
you know health benefits etc etc what
would you say as a as a ufc hall of
famer yeah i mean um
health benefits would be one but i mean
i would i would also say uh you know
some kind of
um
portion of the money for the retirement
you know what i'm saying for fighters
who who who who who are done fighting
you know sort of 401k an ira profit sure
okay so so say for instance it's like um
like
you know
if if i'm a fighter and i get paid for a
pay-per-view i should get paid any time
that that fight is being shown even
after i'm retired you know what i'm
saying and i feel like that's that could
make it better like for instance like
any time the show was shot up in this
fight i should be is that how his
unboxing does boxing do that or
no i don't i don't think about i don't
think boxing does it like that but i'm
saying that's something that could help
that's something that could help out
because they're still getting money to
pay like the ufc is getting money to
[ __ ] you know to licenses
they're making some money yeah so
they're making money so if they're
making money on sean and rashad evans
fight yeah then rashad admits you get
paid off of it yeah i'm saying even if
i'm not fighting a current fighter you
see when i was in la i was uh
handling finances for a few nfl players
and they would all complain about
retirement and say hey they don't pay
this they don't pay that they don't pay
enough right
uh
and then but at the same time it was hey
you know i always watch how you take
care of your champions okay you can't
take care of everybody but how you take
care of your champions for example like
you know how
uh
people can say whatever they want to say
about mark cuban and who he is he takes
care of his best guys look at dirk he's
been taken care of for 20 years turk's
like i can go a lot of different places
miss i love my boss i'll work over here
the guy gives me what he wants so he
takes care of him right
do you do you think ufc takes care of
their champions like not everybody
because i can see how that can be
watered down and this guy's saying give
me this and that guy's saying give me
this but there is a system for
guys who were champions right do they do
that is there benefits for you guys yeah
absolutely i mean you know
if i call dana and ask him for anything
you know he'd be like yeah absolutely he
seems like that yeah yeah
he's that guy dana's dana's um you know
he has a kind of persona out you know
when you see him on camera but you know
dana's one of the coolest guys you ever
meet and he's and he's straight up you
know what i'm saying like you may not
like what he says but you're gonna know
that he's speaking from the heart you
know what i'm saying you're gonna know
where you stand with them and i can
always handle that you know what i'm
saying i don't always gotta like what
somebody say but if they're kind of you
know shooting straight from the hips
then i can accept that and dana's one of
those guys so um and and you know he
does take care of his champions you know
he um he makes sure that he does
whatever he can you know he's he's one
of those guys who
who does things and doesn't say anything
about it like people doesn't people
don't really know how generous dana is
and the things that he do do because he
doesn't he's not one of those guys say
oh i did this and he doesn't brag about
it at all he just does it so so would
you say behind close like francis said
the other day he had a private meeting
with dana and he said what a great
conversation he had with him like he was
very
uh positive about the conversation would
you say behind closed doors champions
love dana and have a great relationship
with dana absolutely okay i think that
that's that's the i think that right
there finishes the conversation if you
ask me is dana white the greatest
commissioner in the history of sports
you've had david stern in the nba paul
tagliabue nfl good dell uh buddy celine
would you count vince mcmahon
vince mcmahon okay but is dana white i
would be probably on the promoter side
yeah that would be you know is he i was
i would say uh he's definitely up there
you know when it comes to um
just being the guy who's you know able
to relate on so many different levels
you know that's that's what dana does
dana can uh come at you from a different
perspective and he can understand where
you're coming from and he doesn't uh he
doesn't big time you you know and that's
and that's that's that's a huge thing
because you know sometimes when you
don't have the same value that they can
get out of you people have the tendency
to kind of dismiss you but dana dana
doesn't do that and that's one thing
that you know um
i can say that you know stands
high in history you know in in his
character and who he is as a person
because he always makes sure to you know
yeah he'll return a text you know no
matter how busy he is he had returned a
text he'd return a call so you know he's
one of those guys so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]